[Music]
well i'm very very excited to be sitting
here with one of the top figure skaters
in the world ashley wagner i was
watching a tape of hers earlier and it
was transcendent
i had epiphanies watching your movements
how long have you been skating i have
been skating since i was five years old
was that your idea
absolutely not
do you get dizzy and if you do how do
you keep skating i don't get dizzy you
don't no that's impossible yeah it's an
out of body experience i'm from the top
looking down and i see my body spinning
really no but that'd be awesome that
would be awesome so most skaters uh when
they spin in the air they go
counterclockwise and you go clockwise
yes i'm the weirdo amongst the figure
skating community yeah you're like a
toilet in the southern hemisphere
exactly i'm an australian toilet i never
describe myself as that
anyway so um i'm considered a lefty but
i escaped to the right and there's no
coming back from this no it was the best
moment we've had all week as it was
coming out of my mouth i was like no
come back trust me the only way to
succeed is to own it so if you weren't a
figure skater what do you think you
would do somehow involved in broadcast
journalism yeah like this exactly like
this oh my god you should interview me
okay
all right so hello everybody i am ashley
wagner and i am here today with pete
holmes
who
as some of you may know is a comedian
and i have a couple questions to ask him
today i'm so excited to be here ashley
thank you oh yeah i forgot to give you
time to speak i'm sorry it's okay i get
so nervous
[Laughter]
this has been my interview with one of
the best figure skaters in the world a w
root beer the ashwag
ashley wagner
[Music]